there's no such thing as a perfect
infinite mind organization there's no
such thing as a perfect infinite minded
leader right and and companies go like
this like I said any company that's had
any kind of success started infinite
minded idealistic entrepreneurs who
wanted to change the world and we're
totally unrealistic
of course it's imminent minded and they
they become finite minded right and the
question is whether they can they can
get it back again not follow that
standard business curve I'm I'm
impressed by I mean Airbnb has publicly
announced that they want to be a more
infinite minded organization and they
want to run their company differently
and I think they're trying and I I find
that fascinating we cannot ignore Elon
Musk
he speaks an idealized terms and his
ability to take a vision into multiple
different businesses because that's a
good test you know whether you can
repeat it in an entirely different
industry over and over again even though
it's all based on the same basic vision
that cannot be ignored I'm curious about
the companies that have been aren't and
may could be again I talked about
Microsoft I've talked about Walmart I
think apples are apples up for grabs you
know I think Apple is not as finite as
some but it's more finite than it used
to be and I think we noticed the
difference
[Music]